i was in high school my volleyball team  had a sleepover we decided it would be  fun  as a joke to tp our own quarterback and  blame it on the rival  school we went to his house and had over  a hundred rolls of toilet paper  i'm telling you this man's house was  covered from top to bottom in toilet  paper  we wrote on the driveway 10 days cls cls  was the rival school that the football  team was playing in 10 days quarterback  wakes up  sees his house destroyed immediately the  schools were both notified  bible schools coaches questioned their  team who obviously had no idea what  happened  our school was pissed the football team  ended up playing them and beating them  by  60 points and it's funny we had girls  that were dating football players  and they still never got caught the  funny thing is though that quarterback  is actually in the nfl today comment  below your guess on who it is